[Música]
momento de nuestra revista de prensa
aquí en directo a América de France 24
Bienvenida al estudio martamoya un día
más Gracias Rosa Buenos días y empezamos
con la noticia de ayer y de hoy y es el
peor naufragio del año en el
Mediterráneo no y nos trae como lo
abordan las portadas europeas
concretamente de los países del
Mediterráneo si Rosa vamos a empezar con
Tania un periódico griego que titula
este jueves Cuántos migrantes muertos
podemos tolerar el occidente civilizado
frente a su responsabilidades muestra en
esa portada la trayectoria de la
embarcación que salía de las costas
libias con destino a Italia y al menos
79 personas fallecieron en este trayecto
a la altura de la localidad de pilos
también dice esta portada la Europa
moderna permitió la muerte de 1.116
personas en lo corrió del año en aguas
del Mediterráneo Por otra parte hemos
destacado en la portada de liberación
que titula su cementerio una portada muy
gráfica y dice al menos 79 migrantes
muertos en el Mediterráneo solo hay 104
supervivientes y es una de las peores
tragedias en lo que va de año en las
costas mediterráneas dice además
Liberación que Europa deberá poner el
foco otra vez y repensar su política de
asilo aunque las expectativas no son
muchas como ya sabemos por otra parte IL
manifesto en Italia ayer se desmarcó del
resto de portadas italianas con el
funeral de estado a Silvio berlusconi y
titula luto universal en naufragio en la
Península del peloponeso es una masacre
eso dice el manifiesto se piensa que
habría más de 700 personas en esa
embarcación de las cuales 79 al menos
han fallecido 104 han sido rescatadas
por tanto el número de fallecidos podría
ser mucho más elevado y lo que se está
buscando en estos momentos son cuerpos y
no supervivientes y por otra el país de
España dice al menos 79 muertos en el
naufragio en el barco en el mar jónico
un pesquero que transportaba a migrantes
sirios pakistaníes y egipcios entre
otros aunque como decimos el número es
todavía indeterminado y Marta y
precisamente no la Unión Europea
continúa poniendo el foco en los grupos
a que proveen estas embarcaciones
irregulares no que hacen negocio de
estas rutas irregulares y no en la falta
de alternativas legales que permite Pues
bueno que fuerza la gente a utilizar
estas vías clandestinas en fin cambiemos
de tema Marta Porque en los medios
chinos hablan del papel que podría jugar
Beijing en el conflicto entre Israel y
Palestina no Sí Rosa hemos destacado la
portada del global Times como sabemos un
periódico muy al final Partido Comunista
chino que titula este jueves China y
Palestina elevan sus relaciones a una
asociación estratégica todo esto
enmarcado en la visita a Beijing de la
autoridad Palestina que es más mudabas
china se presentó como potencial
mediador en el conflicto israelí para el
destino y propuso un plan de tres puntos
para acabar con las tensiones un plan un
poco osado Y quizá no tan bueno con
Israel en los tres puntos son el
establecimiento de un estado
independiente
palestino la satisfacción de las
necesidades económicas y de subsistencia
de los palestinos y sobre todo mantener
las negociaciones la dirección correcta
de las negociaciones de Paz Por otra
parte hemos destacado el post que
analiza un poco el papel que puede jugar
China y la relación de Beijing con ambas
partes del conflicto sobre el papel que
puede jugar china Lo mismo que destacaba
pues el global Times no con esos tres
puntos y con las relaciones Pues con los
palestinos dice este análisis del post
que china fue uno de los primeros países
en reconocer a Palestina como soberano
en el año
1988 que ha defendido a Palestina ante
la ONU reiteradamente frente a la
ocupación israelí que ha habido
numerosas visitas de mandatarios
palestinos a Beijing a lo largo de los
años y que ambos se declaran como viejos
y buenos amigos aunque los expertos
dicen que esta relación Es más retórica
que de acción por otra parte con los
israelíes Bueno pues china reconoció a
Israel en el año
1992 como país soberano desde el año
2000 las relaciones bilaterales se
estrecharon muchísimo sobre todo en el
plano económico de hecho china es el
segundo socio comercial de Israel solo
por detrás de Estados Unidos Aunque
también ha habido tensiones Pues por las
tensiones también a sí mismo entre China
y Estados Unidos y porque Bueno pues al
final china ha denunciado ante la ONU
pues estos ataques israelíes en
territorio palestino Rosa Bueno pues si
china pasa a la acción en la mediación
de este conflicto Marta pues ese era un
incalculable no así es y hablando de
diplomacia precisamente parece que hay
gente trabajando por debajo de la mesa
para que el mundo no Se aboque una
catástrofe nuclear no y nos lo revela el
New York Times precisamente Pues sí Rosa
hablamos de Irán y Estados Unidos que
habría conversaciones tácitas y por
debajo de la mesa que hablarían de un
resurgimiento diplomático entre estos
dos países según funcionarios de Israel
y las propias Irán y Estados Unidos ha
habido conversaciones en primavera en el
Golfo de omán con el objetivo de
alcanzar un acuerdo informal no escrito
que funcionarios iraníes destacan como
un alto al fuego político Irán se
comprometería a no enriquecer su uranio
por encima del 60% de pureza de tener
ataques contra contratistas
estadounidenses en Siria e Irak no
vender misiles balísticos a Rusia y
liberar a tres presos irá no
estadounidenses Por otra parte Estados
Unidos se comprometería en este pacto
que se supone se está alcanzando por
debajo de la mesa a evitar endurecer las
sanciones económicas contrate eran a no
confiscar petroleros extranjeros a no
Buscar resoluciones punitivas contra
Irán en la ONU o en la agencia
internacional de energía atómica y a
descongelar miles de millones de dólares
activos iraníes para fines humanitarios
según un funcionario de Israel el pacto
Sería inminente bueno Pues ojalá ojalá
llegue Marta y rápidamente nos queda
mucho tiempo parece que parte del
infierno está en Polonia No pues sí Rosa
esto ya bueno Es casi una broma hay una
península polaca que se llama gel que no
es gel con dos geles como el infierno en
Estados Unidos o el infierno el inglés
Mejor dicho pero que ha sido objeto de
crítica porque
en la ruta que te llevaba en bus a esta
península polaca era las 666 no el
número asociado al y al infierno
una idea que nació en 2006 y que durante
años ha traído a miles de turistas tanto
polacos como de otros puntos del mundo
ahora un grupo de cristianos ha
protestado por este hecho porque la ruta
se llama 666 y la empresa concesionaria
de los buses ha cambiado la ruta a
partir del 24 de junio va a operar la
ruta 669 hasta esta península polaca de
gel lo que muchos consideran que es un
fallo total de estrategia de marketing
totalmente Marta Cuántos turistas no va
a perder no Polonia después de Pues
digamos a cambiar esta ruta de bus
simplemente un hecho así como puede
afectar también a la economía polaca
bueno Marta Muchísimas gracias por esta
revista de prensa mañana con más aquí en
directo América gracias